[Music]
on this Friday night grounded in Sudan
why Ottawa has caused rescue flights as
people wait to escape and the violence
rages despite a ceasefire the situation
is dangerous it is volatile it is
intense
I'm on the picket lines among federal
workers
the never-ending policing Saga in Surrey
BC it is a unique situation The Province
weighs in on whether the city should
ditch the RCMP the potential Nationwide
Ripple effects
plus fast on her feet and in first place
let's hear it for a world champion the
Canadian who danced her way to victory
at an elite competition
global national
para Nasser
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news tonight two
more Canadian rescue flights have just
departed Sudan that update from defense
minister Anita Anand a short time ago
she did not say how many Canadians were
on board but this news comes after a
volatile day on the ground nearly two
weeks after the violent conflict erupted
Michael Olay has our top story tonight
it's becoming increasingly difficult to
live as a civilian in Sudan even the
Street Markets have become battle zones
and this is during a supposed ceasefire
the lineup to get out of Africa's third
largest country is getting longer these
women have been waiting four days for a
bus they can afford what used to cost
sixty dollars now goes for over 500. the
lucky few are those with foreign
passports
nearly two weeks into the conflict
Germany has now ended its Rescue Mission
Canada meanwhile is just getting started
facing criticism it's been slow moving
and disorganized that is not the case on
my understanding the first two Canadian
planes left Sudan Thursday but other
flights have been disrupted over
mechanical issues problems with the
overused runway in hartum and security
concerns after a Turkish transport plane
was shot at and began spilling fuel out
of one of its wings yes of course
there's risks and arguably that's what
your people are people in the Canadian
Forces manage you don't want to take
unacceptable risks of course you don't
know what the bad guy is going to do but
a whole bunch of other nations are
flying so quite frankly we should too
Canada and other countries have soldiers
on the ground to provide security at the
airport but while the Sudanese
government has allowed evacuation
flights to land it can't control the
chaos outside the airport and it
certainly can ensure planes won't be
fired upon all of that paints a picture
that the situation is dangerous it is
volatile it is intense and we need to do
whatever we can to ensure the safety and
security of Canadians to the airport a
difficult task as the demand to leave
increases microwave Global News Toronto
there's some movement tonight in the
federal Public Service labor dispute
that's impacting key Services across
this country the federal government has
presented an offer to the union now it's
unclear if a deal is Within Reach but
negotiations are expected to run through
the weekend and picket lines are going
strong as more than a hundred and fifty
thousand government workers demand
better pay and flexibility for remote
work Mackenzie gray reports
this hot dog stand set up outside the
prime minister's office
was party central for striking public
servants everybody seems to giving high
five of fist bumps like everybody's
cheering that positivity seemed to have
made its way to the bargaining table
with the Liberals presenting a new offer
to the public service Alliance of Canada
this afternoon we know that our
negotiators are putting forward serious
offers and working constructively both
sides are tight-lipped on the details of
the new offer but the main sticking
point remains wages the union had been
asking for a 13.5 percent increase over
three years but psych said it dropped
its request this week by how much it
won't say as for the Liberals they stood
firm in their previous offer of nine
percent over three years offering nine
percent is just completely disrespectful
like it's way under inflation the other
key issue the union wants the right to
work from home in the Collective
Agreement so they can grieve managers
that Force employees into the office the
liberal policy has civil service events
physically at work for two to three days
a week but that's not good enough for
some on the picket line I think without
ain't shining this in the Collective
Agreement there is probably a 90 chance
that it's backed to work five days a
week but for most of the psac members
it's been five days a week protesting
with treasury board confirming that an
average of 71 000 employees have
withdrawn their services every day
because of the strike I would suspect
we're closer to the end of this thing
than the beginning there are only two
ways it can end one is a negotiated
settlement and the other is Back To Work
legislation the hot dog stand is closed
and the protesters have gone home until
Monday but both the union and the
federal Governor said they're willing to
work through the weekend pharah to try
and hammer out a deal
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you for
that Mackenzie and you heard him in
McKenzie's report prime minister Justin
Trudeau though has been heavily
criticized for not being in Ottawa as
this strike drags on instead today he
was wrapping up his trip in New York
pitching Business Leaders on Canada's
investment appeal and answering
questions over this nation's involvement
in one of the continent's fastest
growing humanitarian crises garcha
reports
the prime minister's visit to New York
City coming to a close with a keynote
address to the Council on Foreign
Relations you know who makes some of the
cleanest Steel in the world
workers in Canada
Trudeau spoke to the group of Investors
Business Leaders and Venture capitalists
about the country's investment interests
pitching Canada as a strong critical
minerals trade partner Volkswagen made
the decision to come to Canada
because over the past eight years we've
been working on environmental standards
the Prime Minister also discussed calls
for Ottawa to step up support for Haiti
the U.N says the worsening political
crisis and growing violence has led to
unprecedented insecurity in the country
women and children are are being abused
and raped people are being kidnapped
people are being killed the security
situation is awful the solution is not
to come with an international Force and
and go to at and said here we take the
control of the place and we're going to
help you
it's it's a guarantee for failure
Trudeau told reporters determining how
to respond is a challenge but Canada is
here to do the work first off that means
supporting the hnp the Haitian National
Police to be able to have the resources
the pay the uniforms the training
necessary I think that the solution and
the long term is to really strengthen
Asian police we don't have a lot of time
to do that and time is of the essence
Canadian officials here say the 100
million dollars Canada is providing to
help Shore up the police in Haiti is the
type of commitment they're encouraging
other countries including the U.S to
make to help strengthen institutions
from within the country pharah
in New York thank you so much nitu after
months of debate and uncertainty BC's
Public Safety Minister has made his
recommendation on the future of policing
in the city of Surrey the province's
second largest municipality despite the
wishes of the newly elected Council the
provincial government is recommending
the city continue with the transition
away from the RCMP to the Syria Police
Service it has been a long costly road
to get here and it's not over yet
Global's Keith baldry joins us from
Victoria Keith how did we even get here
so this Saga began way back in 2018 when
former Suri married Doug McConnell and
his counsel to began the transition away
from the RCMP into their own Municipal
Police Force his successor Brenda
Locke's mayor and her Council reversed
the process saying they wanted to go
back to the RCMP and abandoned the
municipal police force that prompted The
Province to step in and look for some
reports the reports landed today with
minister of Public Safety Mike
Farnsworth releasing his decision which
was a strong recommendation for Surrey
to continue the transition to its own
Municipal Police Force the key finding
the RCMP does not have adequate Staffing
levels to be guaranteed to provide
adequate safety levels for Syria
citizens also the first time today
announced the provinces willing to
assist with the considerable cost
associated with making the transition
here's Minister Mike farnworth and that
one of the best ways to ensure that that
transition takes place smoothly is to
recognize serious concerns that if by if
you continue with the transition there
would be costs associated to that I
think everyone recognizes the situation
when it comes to Surrey is unique it is
the largest Detachment RCMP Detachment
in the country it is one of the largest
I think after the city of Vancouver uh
in the province of of British Columbia
that this is a very unique situation
so it's going to be interesting that
this transition does proceed it's going
to take about three years to complete it
and it does have potential implications
for right across the country there are a
lot of municipalities currently served
by the RCMP the RCMP brand has taken a
bit of a beating in recent years and I
think there's going to be a lot of
interest the views towards unfolding in
Surrey in Vancouver's backyard over the
next three years as they make the
transition away from the largest RCMP
Detachment in the entire country pharah
Keith baldry and Victoria BC thank you
Keith
we're learning new details tonight about
how Silicon Valley Bank fell apart the
U.S federal reserve is admitting it
failed and says it will now re-examine
how it regulates Banks the US Federal
Reserve released a highly anticipated
report analyzing the country's biggest
bank failure since 2008. it says the
regulator faulted its low standards and
a lack of urgency to force svb to
address its weaknesses that meant the
bank remained well rated even as its
poor governance business model and risk
management led to its insolvency
Russia unleashes a new wave of missiles
over Ukraine coming up the rising
casualties and the clues of a Ukrainian
counter-offensive plus teenage hero the
boy who sprung into action when his bus
driver passed out
and Springtime scorcher the
record-breaking weather baking Spain
to the war in Ukraine now and the
findings if a U.N committee reports this
has been released detailing many of the
human rights violations allegedly
committed by Russian forces and the U.N
pressing Moscow to investigate them
the refusal of the Russian Federation to
address these issues didn't hinder us
from addressing them in our concluding
observations but of course it made our
work more difficult
among the committee's findings were
cases of torture execution arbitrary
detainment rape as well as the forcible
transfer of Ukrainian children all of
which Russia denies including targeted
attacks on civilians yet early today
another round of Russian missiles struck
multiple Ukrainian cities claiming more
civilian lives here's Eric Sorensen
[Music]
a barrage of Russian missiles was shot
down over Ukraine but clearly not all of
them one destroyed a residential
high-rise in Oman
says his neighbors who moved in when he
did 30 years ago are all gone
no one has left he says
the death toll more than 20 and climbing
includes four children
President Vladimir zielinski called for
a moment of silence but also called upon
the Free World to remain committed to
Ukraine's fight
Russia must lose and its leadership must
be punished he said
there are signs that the expected
Ukrainian counter-offensive in the East
is about to start the military is
seeking out Russians with drones as
Ukraine awaits more NATO weapons like
this howitzer
[Applause]
their super says this artillery
Commander better than the old Soviet era
models we're able to push the Russians
back and move the guns more quickly he
says
the counter-offensive will be crucial to
demonstrates in NATO that with its help
Ukraine can succeed says this analyst
the Western world has given an enormous
amount of Aid defensive weapons and so I
think it needs to demonstrate to all of
its allies that it can use those weapons
to good effects and push back Russian
troops
today the pope lamented what's happening
in Ukraine and what he called the
soloists of War while a new U.N report
wants Russia to respond to evidence of
human rights violations is Russia
listening
[Applause]
[Music]
Vladimir Putin today called on Russians
to counter the West's economic
aggressions
Putin has not listened to outside voices
for 14 months and does not appear to be
listening now least of all to ukrainians
like Sergey lubinsky
they don't care he says they want to
kill as many people as they can
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto
Spain hit its hottest ever April
temperature on Thursday with a record
38.8 degrees in the southern city of
Cordoba the scorching figure comes as a
large swath of the country deals with a
blistering heat wave that has
temperatures hovering 10 to 15 degrees
warmer than expected for the month the
Heat's also contributing to a prolonged
drought in the region which is stoking
fears of a repeat of last Summer's
extreme fires there is some good news in
sight though cooler temperatures are
expected over the weekend
[Music]
the monarchy and the mounties ahead the
relationship between the royal family
and the RCMP dating back more than a
century
[Music]
a small delegation of RCMP officers was
at Windsor Castle today to meet with
King Charles III as his majesty
officially assumed his role as
commissioner in Chief the honorary
appointment came with a number of Royal
gifts from Canada's police force
including a prized horse that resembles
one given to the late Queen Elizabeth
decades ago Crystal commencing Reports
the Royal Canadian Mounted Police riding
on the grounds of the oldest and largest
inhabited castle in the world
a special ceremony with King Charles III
in honor of the rcmp's 150th anniversary
and the upcoming coronation of the king
Charles is now the rcmp's commissioner
and chief a ceremonial role that was
only created in 2012 for the late Queen
Elizabeth in honor of her Diamond
Jubilee but the connection between the
service and The Sovereign goes back much
further it's a relationship that that
stretches way back to 1897 when some
members of what was then the Northwest
Mounted Police participated in the
Jubilee ceremony for Queen Victoria the
cavalry's equestrian skills have led to
a unique bond this is the first horse
from the RCMP Musical Ride for the king
Noble a seven-year-old black mayor
the queen was given eight horses this
one Burmese was the first one given to
her by the RCMP and she wrote it for
years during trooping the color sergeant
major Scott Williamson rode at her
funeral being part of the service at
Windsor Castle with King Charles he says
was heart pounding you want to do our
best when we're doing these things we
rehearse and prepare
but then his majesty comes and he's very
relaxed and he immediately puts
everybody in in kind of a relaxing tone
the red surge against the historic
Castle Gates attracted a lot of
attention some wanted to know more about
Noble having heard of the horse's
background in the musical ride so to be
able to gift Noble to his majesty
says to us the RCMP answers to Canada
that this special relationship this
personal relationship is going to
continue the king its hoped will
eventually ride Noble when his own horse
is retired the Handover appeared to go
well with lots of smiles and while we
couldn't hear what was said clearly a
few jokes were made the pressure however
is coming five RCMP members will be
riding in the procession on Coronation
Day and they will all be on horses
gifted to the Royals including Noble
it's hoped that by seeing them in their
uniforms taking part in a historic event
will bring a sense of Pride to those
watching back home Farah I'm sure
crystal gemancing in London thank you
for that
[Music]
[Applause]
next the top honor for this Elite
Canadian Irish dancer
[Music]
a seventh grader in Michigan is being
hailed a hero after he's sprung into
action when his school bus driver fell
unconscious
[Music]
the driver reported feeling unwell just
before passing out the vehicle then
began to Veer into oncoming traffic and
that's when 13 year old Dylan Reeves
jumped in calmly taking the wheel and
bringing the bus to a stop
the driver is recovering in hospital and
there was no damage to the bus
when police called Dylan's parents his
dad thought his son was in trouble and
then they told him this is a good call
your son is a hero
with a little bit of Irish luck and a
lifetime of training and skill a Calgary
woman has fulfilled a dream of a
lifetime Mackenzie Mahler is now a
two-time world champion in Irish dancing
the grad student beat out athletes from
across the U.S Australia and the UK now
as Heather York's West reports she's
hoping to inspire a new generation to
the athletic art form
it was a moment of pure joy
[Applause]
after two decades of training and
dedication Mackenzie Mueller claimed
Irish dancing's top prize let's hear it
for a world champion and it was yeah
just so exciting when the results came
out and yeah we got to have that moment
back in her home studio in Calgary
baller says it was an honor to win the
title with the Championships held in
Montreal and she beat out favorites from
around the world including dancers from
Ireland itself
pretty special to win the worlds on our
home turf definitely flying the flag for
Canada
[Applause]
popularized in the 90s by the success of
shows like Riverdance Irish dancing
requires an incredible level of
athleticism for the world's Mueller
trained for hours every day it's so fun
I don't mind all the hard work I enjoy
being here and putting in the time
Mueller is studying to be a sports
performance psychologist but she says
Irish dance will always be part of her
life
whether she's perfecting footwork or
passing on the steps to a new generation
of performers it's just so exciting to
get to see those light bulb moments that
I remember having as a kid
um and getting to see the excitement and
the passion for it come up in somebody
The Dance Sport may have Ireland's name
but this year a Canadian wears the crown
Heather urich's West Global News Calgary
and that's global national for this
Friday night I'm Farah Nasser and on
behalf of our whole crew I want to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us
[Music]
this is ottawa's Wellington Street right
in front of Parliament Hill late this
afternoon it reopened to Vehicles nearly
15 months after it was closed because of
the so-called Freedom Convoy protest
over the past two weeks Crews have set
up new traffic signals repainted traffic
lanes and opened a bike lane until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
take care of each other
good night
[Music]
foreign